now Gord why did you come here why are
you supporting Waterkeeper Alliance well
I've been trustee for the Lake Ontario
water keepers for some time now working
with Marc Matson and Kristin Tully back
there in Ontario for the great lake they
call Ontario and and obviously it's an
easy one for me I've been sort of you
know obviously wanting to be involved
forever and wanting to be involved in a
meaningful grassroots kind of way mark
asked me to learn the ropes and I and
that's what I wanted as well he wanted
it for me wanted of me and so I did and
obviously you know we can sort of
continue asking our neighbors to be less
bad and changed their lightbulbs and
drive different cars but until these
huge multinational corporate polluters
stop using our lakes and rivers as
toilets that's really not going to mean
too much water keepers our boat echo
justice they're about using pesky little
thing called the law to to protect our
lakes rivers streams or swimming fishing
and drinking which are they're not
privileges those are our rights we we
own them there in the public trust so
this type of stuff resonated with me
instantly and I didn't need any arm
twisting on here with a lot of people
with you know very um lofty ideas and
deep pockets and to raise money for a
very worthy organization and only too
pleased to be here and thrilled about it
in fact yeah
you're here you brought your family are
you getting a chance to actually enjoy
yourself as well and take in the natural
beauty of them no I probably kids out
here to stuff envelopes and no no I
wanted them to come I wanted them to
hear Bobby speak actually and and I wish
well I know more people will
but also yeah to to ski and to enjoy the
Rockies to enjoy this venerable hotel
brand old lady and and it's a chance
I've been on the road for about a year
and a half so it's really a chance for
us to have a little time together if you
could do a shout out to Canada what
Canadians do to protect our waters
Canadians can really just demand that
they're able to enjoy them they
shouldn't put up with beach closings and
chain-link fences and because a
generation has now gone by where people
actually don't even think to know that
that that's not right we just starting
to accept it yeah so I would say don't
accept it they like I say that it's a
it's our right